by getting close to them he's making
some grand new observations which if
true could change the scientific view of
black bear behavior I believe that the
process that I use produces more
accurate results than science can for 12
years he has been gathering hundreds of
hours of video footage Ben believes this
will reveal a social world with
similarities to our own the striking
thing about bears is their social
behavior and I believe it to be a mirror
of a behavior that allowed humans to
succeed in the first place
it's April Ben is making his way off the
mountain to where six months ago he last
saw a pregnant squirty disappearing into
her den to hibernate what a good girl
what a good girl from November to April
bears go without food or water surviving
by dropping their temperature a few
degrees I've just been to squirty's den
she's friendly this year and has two new
Cubs she was hanging above the den in
the Sun catching some rays from spring
to fall every year Ben spends as much
time with squirty as possible with her
health and his special gift to read
bears he is gaining new insights into
bear behavior
it's beautiful day up here and I'll head
back down over the mountain and wait to
see squirty in a few more weeks
what makes this relationship between man
and bear possible is that it began when
she was a carbon 12 years ago when
squirty was seven weeks old her mother
disappeared
Wildlife officers found her and her
siblings and handed them over to Ben the
only person in New Hampshire licensed to
rehabilitate wild bears Ben became the
only man ever to successfully hand raise
black bear cubs when he controversially
crossed the divide between man and
animal by taking on the role of a bear
parent when Sparty came to us she
weighed about three pounds and she was
seven weeks old her eyes had just opened
her his little ear flaps are still down
she wobbled when she tried to walk she
and her siblings were very very tiny
they had no experience with her mother's
outside the den been taught the cups
everything they needed to survive
amazingly this came to him quite
naturally but it made some scientists
uneasy they were afraid his close
contact with the Cubs would reduce their
fear of man and jeopardize their
survival in the wild
this only may been more determined every
field of science is like a club it has
rules and these rules will be you can't
work with obituaries bears or you can't
have close association with bears well
rules like that you're never going to
learn anything